good morning today I don't start filming
until 7 p.m. so we have the whole day
ahead of us
what should we do toast towels I put the
milk first [ __ ] having breakfast marzia
me too I've been reading some of the
comments on the blogs and it's honestly
some of the nicest comments I've ever
received on the channel so thank you so
ken has his little corgis so cute oh
[ __ ] oh god I hate these beer mode you
can also slow time well that doesn't
help if you suck two more seconds
where's the tram Curtis go in yeah to
the Napo babe five more days and you
bros will be able to play it what are
you doing okay what do you got for us
cog awfully tell me everything a lot pug
awfully in one sentence it's monopoly
but with pugs the mailman just
recognized me that's funny but I saw
that there's something at our gate I
think the time has finally come that you
bros figured out where I live huh what
is this contact lens case dark chocolate
picture of a pug that's kind of sweet
got your favorite team thankfully on
Terry gotta kind of bit
Oh who's gonna get all that money
make it rain make it rain make it rain
on them are you feeling
I was intense monopoly i won for sure
alright we're heading out today is
Cancun's birthday Oh
everyone goes say happy birthday uber is
here there was a tsunami warning here
today
obviously here we go
my god Felix is gonna die
yeah goes get we can go close this
Oh
I say your great day I don't have shorts
you win good job you win what are they
doing they're cleaning away no don't go
you're disappearing yeah place time to
get naked
nevermind okay camera girl
probably not the cleanest water but that
was so nice
honey I'm home Phoenix did you try to
summon taken again
oh you city water cottage I like how the
prologue is getting fan oh that's cool
I don't know if you can tell but I got
proper sunburn go Oh God Oh cringe
I really really miss anger right now but
I'm fellow gangsters goodbye Thomas
peace be with you hey guys this door
doesn't open anymore
go down and come up again go down and
come up again I got I got fine I am
sitting in a chair in a room doing a Q&A
I get to change in private okay today
where is it same as always
Jesus Christ this is my outfit what
happened no one wanna honey a mom what
are you doing being weird it's really
weak uh uh yeah yeah time to sleep
Thank You rose for another awesome day
thank you much yeah see breasts tomorrow
and as always thank you for keep doing
that
we're gonna die we're gonna die
I got a research thing in today tell me
how jelly you are feel free to tell me